it's hard soft cute way to dare cheek be
cup oh my goodness use to excrete but
thank you for giving me some personal
space okay this is little worse now okay
hello everybody my name is markiplier
you're not even paying attention the
cameraman what if I'm offset I'm sorry I
look off-center am I even in center miss
your your positions very nicely I okay
fine I'll Center it why didn't it need
to be centered I just want to look you
were offset a little oh the two-thirds
rule third rule the third thing
okay so hello everybody my name is
markiplier and I'm making a quick vlog
because Matt Ryan and I are actually
going to a performance that we are
performing it because I told you guys if
we do those my balls
thank you chica but we're doing an
improv chica I'm trying to talk here
we're doing an improv performance here
for just friends and family and stuff
but I want to let you guys know that
we've been working on a ton of crap and
I'm gonna be trying to solve this
Rubik's Cube right got a new one this
one works better than the other one even
though it's a stupid beat you but it
works better so I'm gonna be trying to
solve this at the same time also while
chica is assaulting me with her bad news
Thank You chica I love you too
assaulting me with their terrible breath
and give me kisses of life so while I'm
salt of clocks already started I guess
so but I didn't want to talk about it
because we have been working on a lot of
stuff in the background a lot of stuff
that you guys probably haven't been able
to see mostly just because well it's not
ready yet but we've been working on not
only taking this improv class but Matt
we can work on writing a TV script of
violet to think like an actual script
for a scripted comedy show TV star for
like really big and it's nothing that we
have anything to show about yet it's
nothing that we'd be willing to you know
talk about just at this juncture in time
but it's something big that we've wanted
to do for a while and we kind of alluded
to and hinted at before and we finally
actually have some progress made on it
to the point where the script is
actually done so while it may seem like
you know video schedule uploads have
been good and like I've been keeping
pace with pretty much everything thanks
to Matt editing and Ryan helping out
with what he has and we've been able to
make some good stuff since we got back
for the new year but I just want to let
you guys know that we have been on
believably busy thanks for licking your
crotch on camera I'm sure everyone at
home really appreciates that thanks
chica you're a doll you're a sweetie put
you're the sweetest sweetest put that
ever put and
I'm not gonna beat any record times on
this one I know for a fact but I just
wanted to say that thank you guys
everyone for being so patient on like
with us while we're getting like the
higher quality stuff out because we're
not trying to get away from like the
sketches and stuff
it's just that our time schedule has
been crazy because not only it would be
you know going to improv for three hours
a day and then doing extra and proper
another two hours on some days and then
working on it so we've been getting a
flick on a regular schedule like adults
yeah fire it yeah look at the word dull
okay it's okay point like we're we're
adults who have been doing adult things
and going to the gym working out like I
promised I would for my new year's
resolution look at that muscle Jacob
look out what I am we're gonna be going
for the performance today and I just
wanted to say thank you guys so much
also reading your comments we'll start
back up on Monday
I fully aim to get that every week from
then on I just going to catch up with
things because after this week we're not
gonna be taking the intensive improv
classes anymore and we should be okay so
thank you everybody for watching and
thank you everybody so much for
supporting and thank you everybody so
much for believe
thank you everyone who bought a cat vs.
dog shirt those are limited edition you
can find a link in the description if
you don't know about
yeah but limited edition and $10,000
will be donated to the Best Friends
Animal Society and I still haven't come
up with the thing for the winner but
we'll come up with something later
didn't guarantee you that
dogs your way there's a cat heart day
right Matt no no okay so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always see you in the next video oh god
oh you got bigger oh yeah